garrett cole the yankees opening day
starter making his second start for the
yanks he went five and a third allowed
two runs against the blue jays cedric
mullins top of the order for the orioles
the one-two and mullins laces it into
center field there is hit number 11 for
cedric mullins
mullins is on and he's a threat to run
and trey mancini stepping up to the
plate mullins takes his lead at first
he's running
pitch outside
and he's in with a stolen base cedric
mullins who has his first stolen base of
the season two and two pitch
that is spiked in the dirt gets by
higashiyoka and mullins moves up to
third base
swinging and a miss mancini down on
strikes cole ends up picking up this
strikeout yankees bring the infield in
for santander
grounded and grabbed there by bruce he's
coming home perfect throw gets mullins
nice play by jay bruce
beautiful play by jay bruce it was a hot
shot he was playing in
bruce backhanded it cleanly
and then threw home and got him that was
a really good play by jay bruce here's
ryan mount castle
popped
and bruce makes the call and the catch
cole pitches out of trouble with a
runner at third and dean cramer going to
face that yankees lineup here the
yankees have seen him he made his debut
what a beginning for the yanks they have
the bases loaded no one out
for stanton can strike him out he does
strike out a lot got him big strike out
there one down labor torres steps in 3-2
did he chase they appeal and he rings
him up so now base is loaded two outs
and here's clint frazier
fastball middle the plate strike three
dean cramer clenches his fist and pumps
his arms as he strands the bases loaded
by striking out the side it started out
like a mess and kramer managed to get
out of dodge all the same here is rui
used to lead up
swing and a miss cole picks up his
second strikeout both of them coming off
the slider
swing and a miss
98 upstairs
strikeout number three for cole
and he goes around strikeout number four
for coal he struck out the side dean
kramer struck out the side of the bottom
of the first straining the base is
loaded he's hopeful for an easier second
start off against jay bruce high fly
ball deep right field santander back on
the track he's at the wall see ya home
run bruce the bruce is loose that's why
they got him it's one nothing yankees
garrett cole has a one-nothing lead
thanks to jay bruce and chances
pitch cut out of miss three strikeouts
in a row strikeout number five
swing and a miss and he struck out six
last five outs recorded all via the
striker
strike three
fastball inside corner oh you see you
know that was 100 miles an hour boy is
he hot tonight
strikeout number seven for coal and the
yanks have two on a two out and here is
clint frazier 2-2 on the way breaking
ball popped up
galvez calls for it
he's got it kramer pitches out of
trouble keeps it a one-nothing game the
bases are loaded three straight walks
bruce
and now
that's going to do it for dean cramer
hyde goes to adam plutko and this is uh
quite an assignment for putco base is
loaded you've got le mayhew judge and
then gardner
grounded to short there's one
there's two run scores
but they do get two outs and the yankees
lead two nothing moving to third is
urchella so here's judge now runner at
third two outs
basic right field that'll score a run an
rbi single for judges second hit of the
night it's three nothing eights
garrett cole is cruising he's had eight
strikeouts against the orioles through
his first four innings of work cut out i
missed high fastball so they're a two
down that strikeout number nine for cole
two
2-2
strike three
strikeout number 10 for coal he is
ringing him up
10 strikeouts for garrett cole calls 72
pitches through five innings highest
number of pitches was in the second and
he threw 18. he's been economical swing
and a miss
mancini could not hold up strikeout
number 11 for garrett cole 3-2
strike three strikeout number 12
for garrett cole here we go to the
top of the seventh inning yes garrett
cole is on the hill
he has thrown 88 pitches
a high fly ball to right not deep judge
in a couple of steps to make the catch
one away here's franco
ground ball of short
torres to bruce tour
proud looking for strikeout number 13.
and they get it
what a performance
by garrett cole
he has retired the last 12 in a row 13
strikeouts in seven innings he's hurling
a three nothing shutout one man on and
one away oh here's stanton warner goes
line drive base it down the left field
line hits so hard it goes all the way to
the wall garden around third he's coming
home he'll score it's an rbi double for
stanton it's four or nothing yanks
orioles bring the infield in the mayhew
at the plate with one out runners on
second and third
little tapper galvez coming home the tag
and he's out of there great throw
perfect throw to the
third base side of home plate so now two
outs judge with a couple of hits and
forward backs that one's drilled deep to
left field there it goes
see
ya a long home run for aaron judge a
three-run shot the yankees break it open
they lead seven nothing and now litke
comes on the pitch in the ninth inning
34 year old left-hander and ryan mount
castle comes up two outs for the orioles
in the ninth inning down seven nothing
three two mount castle chops it to short
in the hole again torres he plants fires
to first save mount castle lags it out
i think they're going to look at it
right it is very very close
they call them safe wow there you go
hustle base hit so here is rio ruiz 3-1
pitch ruiz sails it to right sends judge
back on the track at the wall gord rio
ruiz a two-run homer
in the ninth inning first home run of
the year
the o's not to be shut out tonight it's
7-2 yankees in the ninth the one-two
and that'll do it as galvez goes down on
strikes and the yankees win 7-2